you found your own way back all you
needed was in the cloud in hell-blade
Senna was sacrifice the struggle of
coming to terms with past trauma and
guilt comes out in a number of
surprising ways
developer ninja theory channels its
talents for a narrative and presentation
to tell a personal story that is more to
say than initially lets on and will
likely leave you wondering what's real
and what is the part of an elaborate
hallucination in a far-off land covered
in mist and fog a traumatized celtic
warrior named cinema embarks on a
spiritual vision quest to suppress her
inner demons plagued with severe
psychosis cinemas past trauma manifests
itself through audio and visual
hallucinations that often compromise her
well-being
it's me while the main character
experiences many dangers such as
horrific hallucinations of the dead and
emulation from a mad fire-god one larger
threat looms over her constantly early
on Senna was infected with the
corruption which spreads after she
experiences a death though passing off
each failure is another hallucination
the infection will spread further die
enough times and Senna will succumb to
it wiping all of your progress despite
the permit death mechanic hell-blade is
still a largely fair game taking around
8 hours to clear on the hardest
difficulty and experiencing only a
handful of deaths mostly on account of
some vague and awkward objectives coming
off as obtuse the game is largely
balanced with its pacing and difficulty
even going as far as to offer a helpful
auto scaling difficulty system
hell-blade is an introspective
experience albeit with several combat
and interactive story beats throughout
an engine theory cleverly blends
live-action cutscenes with the in-game
graphics giving each occurrence a
somewhat surreal feeling as if you're
watching a live playback of an altered
memory pulling from Celtic and Nordic
lore the fiction of hell-blade evokes a
dire and bleak atmosphere giving the
impression that the world had already
ended leaving Sonora with only the
company of her memories the story takes
a sympathetic approach to portraying
mental illness and isn't at all
interested in showing the differences
between reality and imagination it's all
about cinemas perspective and with their
visions and was truly real being
presented as one in the same on our
journey through the cursed lands Senna
will utilize her skills in combat to
fight an army of berserkers that appear
out of thin air with fast heavy sword
swings as well as up-close hand-to-hand
strikes he'll hack away at your foes
while dodging and paring their strikes
to get the upper hand these combat
sequences are intense and offer the most
thrilling moments of the game
combats true challenge and satisfaction
come from mastering the base combat
mechanics which is fluid and responsive
allowing you to bounce between multiple
foes easily with their inner voices
warning you of incoming strikes the
intrusive inner voices are easily the
most oppressive aspect of cinema
psychosis using binaural audio making
headphones a must for the full effect
you'll experience what it's like to have
several voices in your head into the
mountain can you see it shall we tell
how where to go
[Music]
in many ways it feels like a subversive
take on the common video game trope with
the bodyless companion offering help be
a radio making them a somewhat
distressing presence you desperately
want to keep at arm's length the
effectiveness of the inner voices and
making you uncomfortable is a testament
to the stellar presentation of the game
which uses some rather inventive tricks
to manipulate cinemas perspective and in
turn your own it does well to make you
feel on edge and in a state of confusion
while simultaneously getting you to
focus on the more tangible and true
elements of our surroundings even if
they are still hallucinations the voices
however can be a boon to your survival
such as some rather tricky boss battles
that forced you to switch up strategies
but the instances where they're most
useful or deeper in the game when you're
able to clear through more than a dozen
enemies consecutively a far cry from the
struggles of only fighting two or three
foes many of these battles serve as the
capper for narrative arcs in the story
feeling like a cathartic emotional purge
where you vanquished constructive sento
a psyche while some characters from
Senna was past treated her mental state
as a danger to her it offers the ability
to witness the harmony in the chaos of
her surroundings finding patterns and
solutions that others wouldn't have the
presence of mind to see Senna WA is able
to navigate the various trials thanks to
her unusually heightened perception
which comes out in a number of unique
puzzle solving moments these puzzles
mostly revolve around unlocking doors by
finding glyphs hidden in plain sight
by using Synovus focus which illustrates
her abstract attention to detail while
these puzzles can be clever the same
style occurs far too often making some
of the more drawn-out sequences of chore
but in one of the game's best moments
the shadows themselves hide dangers as
Sinhala rushes from one light source to
another in a dark cavern all the while
memories of her torment and anguish come
flooding in obscuring your vision in the
dash to safety these moments are real
highlight making a seemingly simple
objective into an unnerving experience
which in a way truly sums up what
hell-blade is about while these moments
serve to be some of hell blades most
profound and effecting moments it uses
them sparingly to help break up general
puzzles and obstacles which feels
somewhat bland by comparison
despite the complexity of the narrative
and his presentation combat only happens
when they needs to and puzzle solving
and set peace moments push the story
forward to reveal more about cinemas
motivations which in turn reveals the
struggles the Tormentor preventing her
from moving on pail blades most notable
achievement is the handling of an
incredibly sensitive subject matter
within an engaging and well crafted
action-adventure game at its heart the
story is about Senna was struggle to
come to terms with their illness in the
process she learns to find the strength
within herself to endure and to make
peace with her past and in a profound
and physical way we go through those
same struggles with her and come away
with a better understanding of a peace
is something that many people in the
world struggle with
[Music]